this video is going to be about the
proof of Bell's Theorem but I made
another video explaining the
significance of Bell's Theorem and I
think it would be really helpful to
watch that first so if you haven't
watched that video then click this link
to be taken to it
so hopefully nobody who hasn't watched
the other video is still here remember
that what we wanted to prove today is
Bell's Theorem that entangled particles
communicate to each other faster than
light before I start on the details of
the proof though I'll explain the main
idea last video I told you guys about
something called spin and some weird
experimental facts about it I won't show
you how but it is possible to explain
spin in the framework of quantum
mechanics however say we didn't believe
that anything could go faster than light
then because of EPR quantum mechanics
couldn't be true therefore we'd have to
look for an alternative theory where
nothing ever acted faster than light
we'll call all theories in this category
local theories what this proof is going
to show is that no matter how cleverly
we try we could never come up with the
local theory that could explain spin
we'll do that by a proof by
contradiction in other words we'll start
by believing that it is possible and see
what happens there's one particular
experiment with spin we'll try and
explain let's say I have a source of
electrons with entangled spins this
means that if a and B are a pair if I
choose to measure them both in the same
axis one will be up and the other down
now a and B are sent off to two machines
very far away from each other which
we'll call Alice and Bob Alice and Bob
can each measure the spin of their
electron in three different axes these
are the three axes and we choose them so
that there are a hundred and twenty
degrees apart from each other when a
arrives at Alice Alice randomly chooses
an axis to measure A's spinnin and Bob
does the same thing with B but they do
it independently from each other so
Alice could measure the spin around two
and Bob around three for example if the
machines measure their electron to be
spin up then they flash red or if it's
spin down they flash white some one
notes if the two machines have the same
color or not this experiment is repeated
many times the question is what fraction
of the time will the colors be different
the answer is actually 1/2 and if you're
willing to take my
for it then you can skip this next part
and move on to the most interesting part
of the proof if not stick around and
we'll figure out why that's the case
using the rules of spin from last time
let's say Alice measured around axis 1
and happen to get spin down let's see
how likely Bob is to measure spin down
as well
the reason I can just pick a particular
case like this is because all the other
cases will work out in the same way to
the same result one-third of the time
Bob will choose axis one as well so
since a and B are entangled bulbs
particle will definitely have spin up in
that direction so the colors don't match
what about if Bob measured around access
to because a is down in the first axis B
must be up in the first axis so we just
have to figure out how much of the spin
is pointing in the second direction
actually as you can see this vector is
partially pointing in the negative
direction of access - what does this
mean it means that if you measure the
spin in access - it's either going to be
up or down but more likely to be down so
in this case a and B are more likely
they're not going to have the same spin
and therefore the colors are likely to
be the same
what about XS 3 this is a really similar
story to access - as you can see this
vector is pointing in the negative
direction of access 3 so most of the
time B will be down if its measured in
Access 3 so again Alice and Bob will
most likely have the same color let's
review those three cases again if Bob is
on axis 1 Alice and Bob definitely won't
have the same color if Bob is on axis
two or three though more often than not
Alice and Bob will have the same color
it works out so that overall there is an
exactly 50% chance that Alice and Bob
will have the same color and 50% chance
that they weren't ok so now we're going
to see if a local theory could explain
this result firstly let's think about
what happens when Alice and Bob happen
to pick the same axis a and B have to
have opposite spins in that case we know
that if nothing can go fast
light the only way that this can happen
is if the particles decided what spins
they were while they're still in contact
we don't know how they decide who gets
which spin but the awesome thing about
this argument is that it doesn't matter
all that matters is that each particle a
and B have decided what their spins are
in each of the three directions
beforehand
there are eight possibilities this one
is that a is spin up in axis 1 and 3 but
spin down in access to then of course B
is the opposite it would take a while if
we had to go through every single
possibility but luckily for me we don't
we'll just look at the case where a is
spin up in axis 1 and 3 and spin down
into and the case where a is spin up in
every axis why can we get away with this
because we can get all the other cases
either by swapping which particle we
call a and B which doesn't matter or
swapping the names of the axis which
also doesn't matter convince yourself
that that's true ok so let's consider
the case where a is all spin up if so
what's the chance that Alice and Bob
will have the same color no matter which
axis gets picked a is always up and B is
always down so they're different spins
whenever they adopt this plan what about
the other type of plan this is a is spin
in each axis and underneath B's Alice
and Bob randomly pick an axis and there
are a few possibilities for what happens
Alice could pick one and then Bob could
pick one also and so they have different
colors or he could pick two which means
that they'd have the same color etc and
we just go through and tally up all nine
possibilities and find out that five out
of nine times they're different colors
so in other words if they adopt this
plan they're more likely than not going
to have different colors so that means
whether or not a and B pick a plan like
this or they pick a plan of the previous
type they will always be more likely to
have the same color but as we already
know this isn't the right result so you
see local theories just don't have the
right tools to explain spin I think
that's because spin is a crazy phenomena
that
is nothing like the classical properties
of matter that were used to on the other
hand any local theory is quite classical
because it assumes particles can't
affect each other instantly over
distances which really limits how weird
it can be and in this case it's just two
classical to explain something like spin
so that spells theorem I promised to
cover a couple of topics last time so
I'll work on that but don't expect them
too soon on that optimistic note see you
next time